petit bien s VZ goûter le fr gr Paris
pour affronter le froid les visiteurs et
les exposants se sont donnés rendez-vous
le weekend dernier pour cet événement
festif et convivial depuis 31 ans le
marché de Noël de montiny le Bretonneux
accueille des artisans des commerçant et
des animations petite nouveauté cette
année un espace de restauration comme il
faisait froid on mangeit soit avant à la
maison on faisait le marché
ou on rentrait après pour manger mais là
le fait qu'il y a l'espace
et ben on profite des commerçants sur
place ça fait toute l'activité on est au
Chud et puis voilà en mangeant un bon
aligo un bon aligo il y avait beaucoup
de choses à voir 53 commerçants du
terroir proposant du fois gras du vin de
la charcuterie tout l'aimé de vos repas
de fête mais aussi en intérieur 80
stands de créateurs une bonne occasion
de préparer vos cadeaux de Noël le bijou
que je que je propose aujourd'hui c'est
un bijou un bijou concept un bijou sur
lequel on peut changer les pierres un
bijou qui offre beaucoup de possibilités
contrairement un bijou classique à
monture fixe entre surprise et
retrouvailles les visiteurs sont venus
nombreux à la Ferme du Manet plus de
10000 personnes étai présentes une
recherche qui est effectuée tous les ans
on retrouve aussi des habitués au fil
des années mais on essaye de tous les
ans de
renouveler 30 % des exposants son
renouvelé chaque année ce qui permet bah
d'avoir de nouvelles choses pour les
visiteurs je connais déjà ces choses
mais j'aime bien les retrouver comme si
c'était la première fois ça c'est une
histoire entre guillemets une histoire
d'amour qu'il faut toujours reconduire
et partager avec les gens et les plus
jeunes c'est eux qui vont être les
portes drapeau de ce que savent faire
tous ces gens-là dans l'alimentaire
c'est important la magie de Noël se
soupoudre dans toute la région plaisir
voisin le Bretonneux Limet ou encore
Rambouillet feront place au chalet du
Père Noël et au plat réconfortant
weekend